man trifft sie uns mit voller wucht das
kann man schlecht sagen die modellierung
sind unterschiedlich aber ich kenne ein
paar modellierung die qualitativ sehr
hochwertig sind also das fängt an
wirklich bedenklich zu werden
schwieriger zu werden wahrscheinlich
anfang januar dann haben wir also hohe
fallzahlen und die bevölkerung muss auf
so etwas vorbereitet werden keine panik
um gottes willen auch keine dinge die
wissenschaftlich noch also ungelegte
eier sind das also geht auch gar nicht
aber das was wir jetzt mit sicherheit
sagen können nikon ist da wird sich
verbraten und wir müssen eine strategie
entwickeln ich kann nur soviel sagen die
booster impfung kampagne die wir fahren
wird ein wichtiger bestandteil seien
aber was wird konkret passieren er
lauter war vize weihnachtsruhe geben wie
man damals über eine oster uhr
gesprochen hat wird man doch wieder über
lockdown in regionalen gebieten sprechen
was ist da ihre strategie also das
glaube ich beides glaube ich nicht aber
ich schließen sie aus den leuten beides
also einen harten lockt jetzt vor
weihnachten geben würde ich ausschließen
dass es klar was es mit dabei
weihnachten ich glaube auch da werden
wir keinen harten lockdown haben aber
lassen sie mich doch folgendes aus
führen bevor es immer also diese fragen
schließen sie aus oder machen sie nicht
und so weiter und so fort die führen
anja ins kurze gras war es wichtig ist
wir müssen jetzt auf der grundlage der
neuen daten die wir bekommen haben wir
also erwarten heute eine stellungnahme
des expertenrates wir haben gestern ganz
wichtige informationen aus england
bekommen weil dort ist die omikron
variante schon sehr viel weiter wird
ausgewertet auf der grundlage dieser
neuen erkenntnisse werden wir in den
nächsten tagen unseren plan vorstellen
wenn sie diesen plan ansprechen müssen
dass dann die länder machen oder machen
sie das also ein plan wird der
typischerweise
ausgewertet in der zusammenarbeit von
bund und ländern weil alles was
umgesetzt wird das müssen ja die länder
umsetzen ein teil wird auch vom bund
immer gemacht ich will so viel sagen
also anstatt dass wir jetzt überall so
die sozusagen maßnahmen die kommen
müssen
spekulieren es ist wichtig dass man das
verhalten der bevölkerung beeinflusst
denn die bevölkerung selbst hat kann
einen unfassbar großen anteil bringen